when it's done tapscott and I have a
member of the Global Agenda Council on
the future of government and I've just
received the youth task force report by
the global redesign initiative and I
think it's a great piece of work and
it's so important that young people are
involved because around the world we
have the biggest generation Network and
this little generation is very different
they're enormously influenced a lot of
them are wired they learn and think
differently and at their fingertips they
have the most powerful tool lever for
figuring out what's going on for
informing others and even organizing
collective responses and help the
problems that that the global redesign
initiative is addressing are ultimately
not going to be resolved by my
generation these problems are going to
be handed over can't be and the world is
not a very happy place right now so
we're counting on you to really bring
about the kind of change is necessary to
ensure that the smaller world that your
kids in there will be a better record so
get involved to keep up the great work I
did